wissenschaftlicher durchbruch oder
gefährliches experiment russland
präsentiert erster corona impfstoff der
soll aber noch nicht ausreichend
getestet seien unter druck gesetzt und
auf der flucht oppositionsführerin sich
allofs kaya verlässt belarus und ist
jetzt in litauen wie der außenminister
dort bestätigt wassernotstand mitten in
deutschland erste kommunen schlagen
alarm wegen der hitze sind einige
wasserspeicher leer
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster heute abend willkommen bei
den heute -nachrichten am dienstag
norbert lehmann ist für den sport an
meiner seite einen standort von mir im
rennen um einen corona impfstoff
beansprucht russland seit heute den sieg
kremlchef putin gab persönlich bekannt
den impfstoff namens sputnik fünf
genehmigt zu haben allerdings ohne dass
russland überprüfbare studien
veröffentlicht hätte wie dringend die
welt auf einen impfstoff warte zeigt
diese zahl bei mehr als 20 millionen
menschen ist das virus inzwischen
nachgewiesen worden
nach angaben der
weltgesundheitsorganisation gibt es rund
um den globus inzwischen 167 projekte in
denen nach einem impfstoff geforscht
wird sechs davon haben nach
internationalen standards die
abschließende phase erreicht doch genau
diese standards hat russland nun
offenbar ignoriert an seinem stern
wer hat die anti corona spritze das
mittel gegen die weltweite krise
es ist ein wettlauf der forscher und ein
wettlauf der mächtigen heute nun erklärt
sich der kreml zum sieger samt 3d
werbevideo es soll zeigen wie der
wirkstoff mit dem namen sputnik fünf die
welt vom virus befreit
heute morgen ist der erste impfstoff
gegen die neue corona virusinfektion
zugelassen worden
ich weiß dass er ziemlich effektiv
funktioniert eine stabile immunität
herstellt und ich wiederhole
er hat alle notwendigen überprüfungen
durchlaufen an all dem aber gibt es
erhebliche zweifel hier im galli
institut in moskau wurde der impfstoff
entwickelt das aber laut experten alles
andere als transparent zum einen sollte
es wohl schnell gehen
zum anderen sind solche zulassung
sicherlich mit vorsicht zu genießen dann
wenn signifikante daten zur
arzneimittelsicherheit und auch zur
wirksamkeit des impfstoffes nicht
vorliegen internationaler standard bei
der impfstoff erprobung drei phasen erst
wird die verträglichkeit getestet dann
die mögliche dosis und die antwort des
immunsystems am ende
ganz entscheidend geht es um die
zuverlässigkeit des schutzes tausende
testpersonen sind hier notwendig im
institut in moskau waren ist ganz
offenbar nicht einmal 100 hier warnen
wir vor verfrühter zulassung weil die
entsprechende daten notwendig sind die
allgemein üblich sind
wichtig ist dass ihr dann im laufe der
nächsten teil tatsächlich bis anfang
nächsten jahres mehrere impfstoff
produkte auch in unterschiedlichen
weltregionen zugelassen haben in
deutschland erwartet das unternehmen bei
sonntag im oktober ergebnisse einer
großen klinischen studie auch die
thüringer firma koubek ist mitten in der
erprobung auf dem weg hin zu einem
wirksamen impfstoff gegen das corona
virus für begann oscar warum hat es
putin derart eilig zum einen ist es so
dass hier im land die korona zahlen nach
wie vor hoch sind jeden tag meldet
russland etwa 5000 neuinfektionen und
dieser wert hält sich seit wochen stabil
erst gestern musste präsident putin
warnen dass man ab herbst wohl auch
wieder krankenhausbetten für coop 19
patienten freiheiten müsse und zum
anderen ist es so dass der russische
präsident gerade jetzt erfolgsmeldungen
sehr gut gebrauchen kann
denn seine sagen wir mal zögerliche
corona politik die hat ihm ein
umfragetief eingebracht und dazu kommt
eine schwächelnde wirtschaft
da passt es natürlich irgendwie ganz gut
jetzt diesen angeblichen und jedenfalls
prestigeträchtigen sieg in diesem
weltweiten rennen um einen chor wird 19
impfstoff für sich beanspruchen zu
können
vielen dank für ihre erklärung flügel in
deutschland bleibt die zahl der
neuinfektionen auf einem relativ hohen
niveau allerdings mit deutlichen
unterschieden zwischen den bundesländern
aktuell werden mehr als 40 prozent der
neuen fälle in nordrhein westfalen
gemeldet
insgesamt haben sich im durchschnitt der
letzten woche 910 menschen täglich neu
angesteckt gestern lag der wert noch bei
870 wo in deutschland das corona virus
derzeit mehr kassiert und wo weniger
das können sie in unserer zdf heute
absehen
etwa auf einer interaktiven karte mit
aktuellen zahlen für jeden
einzelnen landkreis persönliche treffen
von politikern auf internationaler ebene
sind in corona zeiten selten geworden
heute ist außenminister maß nach
russland gereist
die lage zwischen beiden ländern ist
angespannt wegen internationaler
konflikte wie in der ukraine und in
syrien
dazu kommt ein mord in berlin für den
die bundesanwaltschaft russland
verantwortlich macht beide länder haben
deshalb schon diplomaten ausgewiesen
aber deutschland hält am dialog fest für
begann berichtet von schwierigem
fahrwasser hatte heiko maas in bezug auf
die deutsch-russischen beziehungen vor
seinem abflug gesprochen
er landete in der eiszeit kaum ein
blickwechsel zwischen den ministern zu
beginn der gespräche die dauerten länger
als geplant der krieg in der ost ukraine
stand auf der tagesordnung ebenso wie
der mord im berliner tiergarten wo maß
mit weiteren reaktionen drohte wir haben
in der vergangenheit vielfach versucht
informationen von russischen behörden zu
bekommen es gab insgesamt 17 anfragen
vom bundeskriminalamt dem bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz und
bundesnachrichtendienst im auftrag des
bundeskanzleramt die uns nicht
weitergebracht haben oder ohne
beantwortung geblieben sechs bomben über
die zuständigen stellen unserer
regierung haben den deutschen kollegen
alle informationen gegeben die sie haben
heiko sagt das reiche nicht aber wir
möchten auch endlich beweise sehen für
die anschuldigungen schlagabtausch auf
offener bühne das ist selten in
diplomatischen kreisen heute passierte
es gleich mehrfach einig waren die
minister sich in ihrer ablehnung der
amerikanischen drohungen gegen die
gaspipeline nord stream 2 dennoch müssen
wir ganz klar festhalten dass sanktionen
zwischen partnern definitiv der falsche
weg sind letztlich bleibt es unsere
souveräne entscheidung woher wir unsere
energie beziehen viele problemfelder
besprochen keinen durchbruch erzielt das
ist wohl das fazit des heutigen besuchs
von heiko maas in russland in belarus
geht präsident lukaschenko nach seinem
umstrittenen wahlsieg weiter mit
gewalt gegen die opposition vor doch
trotz des brutalen vorgehens der polizei
gehen die menschen auf die straße und
protestieren
herausforderin sich yanofsky hat sich
unter starkem druck des autoritären
regimes inzwischen nach litauen in
sicherheit gebracht christiansen
abgekämpft und desillusioniert svetlana
tier an oskar in einem video wendet sich
die 37-jährige an ihrer anhänger ich
habe eine sehr schwere entscheidung
getroffen und ich habe das selbstständig
gemacht
ich weiß viele können mich verstehen
viele werden mich verurteilen und viele
auch hassen
[Musik]
svetlana tier an oskar
präsidentschaftskandidaten und hoffnungs
figur wider willen eingesprungen für
ihren mann der eigentlich antreten
wollte der aber erst ausgeschlossen und
dann festgenommen wurde
ihre kinder brachte sie zur sicherheit
ins ausland jubelnde massen aber auch
wochen der einschüchterung durch das
lukaschenko system und die angst vor
verhaftung oder schlimmeren am mittag
ein weiteres video der selbsterklärten
wahlsiegerin aufgenommen gestern unter
dem druck anwesen der sicherheitskräfte
in der wahlkommission sagen tier an of
skulls mitstreiter
sie liest eine erklärung ab in der sie
ein ende der proteste fordert belarus
ich fordere sie auf das gesetz umsichtig
und respektvoll zu behandeln
ich will kein blut und keine gewalt ich
bitte sich der polizei nicht zu
widersetzen nicht auf die straße zu
gehen um ihr leben nicht zu gefährden
das verlesen der erklärung die
plötzliche flucht nach liter und all das
war nicht freiwillig berichtet ihr team
sie wurde mit sicherheit druck ausgeübt
und sie war gezwungen belarus zu
verlassen
trotz brutal prügelnde sicherheitskräfte
waren gestern nacht in belarus wieder
tausende gegen lukaschenko auf die
straße gegangen
und sie wollen weitermachen auch ohne
tier an oskar ja das östliche mittelmeer
birgt einen schatz wahrscheinlich sogar
einen ziemlich großen erdgas und schon
länger streiten sich vor allem die
türkei und griechenland wem die
vorkommen gehören zuletzt immer heftiger
derzeit sucht ein türkisches
forschungsschiff in griechischen
gewässern nach erdgasquellen dabei
beanspruchten dieses seegebiet südlich
der inseln kastelorizo rhodos und kreta
als wirtschaftszone für sich nun will
die griechische regierung klarheit und
fordert dafür eine dringlichkeitssitzung
der eu außenminister
jörg brase berichtet dass türkische
forschungsschiff rice hat bereits sein
einsatzgebiet erreicht sucht südlich der
griechischen insel kastelorizo nach
erdgasvorkommen begleitet wird das
schiff wie so oft von einer
waffenstarrenden eskorte die botschaft
ist klar wir machen weiter und niemand
wird uns daran hindern aber es wird
niemand behaupten können die türkei habe
keinen gg willen gezeigt das haben wir
aber auf der anderen seite gibt es ein
land mit schlechten absichten wenn
jemand einen schuldigen sucht würde er
ihn in griechenland suchen
auslöser der türkischen reaktion war
dieses treffen vom wochenende
griechenland und ägypten hatten ein
abkommen unterzeichnet das exklusive
wirtschaftszone im mittelmeer definiert
und damit den zugriff auf
energieressourcen die türkei erklärte
das abkommen für ungültig ankara bestehe
auf einer neuverhandlung der seegrenzen
meint der türkische sicherheitsexperte
abdullah ab für die türkei ist klar wenn
es zu einem gegenseitigen schlagabtausch
kommen sollte ist sie dabei wenn es zu
einem gegenseitigen wettrennen kommt ist
sie auch dabei und wenn es krieg
bedeutet daneben
die griechische regierung versetzte die
marine in alarmbereitschaft und erklärte
man lasse sich nicht erpressen
die situation im östlichen mittelmeer
ist extrem besorgniserregend und kann
nur durch dialog gelöst
werden nicht aber durch schritte die die
eskalation vorantreiben und die
spannungen erhöhen
deutschland hat derzeit den eu
ratsvorsitz und versuchte wieder einmal
zwischen den streitparteien zu
vermitteln gestern hat er seine
festnahme in hongkong hohe wellen
geschlagen wie gerade bekannt wird ist
der verleger jimmy lee offenbar auf
kaution wieder freigekommen ist einer
der führenden vertreter der
demokratiebewegung seine zeitung apple
daily berichtet china kritisch schauen
wir auf die deutsche wirtschaft die ist
in der korona pandemie ja massiv
eingebrochen
aber die hoffnung wächst dass sich die
konjunktur schnell erholt das zeigen
auch neue zahlen des zentrums für
europäische wirtschaftsforschung zb und
200 experten von banken versicherungen
und unternehmen werden monatlich befragt
und die sehen die deutsche wirtschaft
wieder im aufwind christina eglseder
berichtet diese firma in hannover
schleift hochpräzisions walzen für die
produktion von folien auf den
tausendstel millimeter kommt es dabei an
der chef der 60 mitarbeiter kann seinen
gewinn während der korona flaute
ebenfalls genau beziffern
er lag bei 0 erholt sich aber schon der
jetzige auftragsbestand zeigt angesichte
dass sich der umsatz wieder auf normalem
niveau einstellen wird
die stimmung zieht an die
konjunkturerwartungen des leibniz
zentrums für europäische
wirtschaftsforschung diw im august
überraschend deutlich angestiegen ein
zeichen der hoffnung die lage aber
weiterhin ernst die talsohle noch nicht
durchschritten so die industrie und
handelskammern die deutsche wirtschaft
ist in der tiefsten wirtschaftskrise die
wir je gemessen haben
daran ändern auch die jüngsten etwas
positiveren zahlen nichts wir haben eine
große verunsicherung bei den betrieben
die zu 50 prozent frühestens im nächsten
jahr eine normalisierung der geschäfte
erleben sie den finanz- und bankensektor
erwarten die vom zb befragten experten
daher sogar eine ertrags
verschlechterung
ich denke das ist ein indikator dafür
dass eine größere insolvenzwelle und
eine belastung für das gesamte
finanzsystem er war
die exportnation deutschland
international vernetzt wie diese firma
in hannover die ihre walzen in alle welt
geliefert ob sich die erwartete
pleitewelle vermeiden lässt hängt auch
davon ab ob es in anderen ländern bald
wieder grund leicht und es gibt ja
offenbar viele unternehmen die schon
jetzt so unter druck sind dass sie sich
unterstützung vom staat erhoffen und
bethmann an der frankfurter börse ja
ähnlich wie bei der lufthansa litten 14
weitere unternehmen dass der staat mit
rettungs kapital bei ihnen einsteigt das
geht aus einer anfrage der grünen
politikern katharina dröge beim
bundeswirtschaftsministerium hervor dort
in berlin wollte man auf nachfrage
allerdings keine namen preisgeben und
welche konzerne es sich handeln könnte
im übrigen auch zum schutz dieser firmen
aber es dürfte sich um unternehmen
handeln die besonders arg von corona
gebeutelt wurden betriebe aus dem
einzelhandel touristikkonzerne
möglicherweise auch mittelständische
autozulieferer
denn gerade in diesen bereichen ist die
auftragslage noch längst nicht wieder
stabil und vielen betrieben droht
finanziell die luft auszugehen
der staat als retter vor der insolvenz
dass gerade viele größere unternehmen
auf staatliche unterstützung hoffen
zeigt wie ernst die lage nach wie vor
ist danke frank wittmann
es ist drückend heiß in deutschland der
letzte regen liegt vielerorts schon
lange zurück jetzt haben erste gemeinden
den notstand ausgerufen weil das
trinkwasser knapp geworden ist
in diesen wochen wird sehr viel
verbraucht beim bewässern der gärten zum
beispiel
außerdem steigt die zahl der privaten
pures gerade in diesem sommer wegen in
dem wegen corona mehr menschen zu hause
geblieben sind
jetzt heißt es also wassersparen dort wo
die speicher leer sind morgen
wassernotstand meldet die feuerwehr
realität am wochenende in deutschland im
niedersächsischen ort langen wichtig ist
dass sie den trinkwasserbedarf also den
trinkwasserverbrauch auf dem ganzen
nötige minimum
reduzieren zeitweise war die
trinkwasserversorgung zusammengebrochen
so was hatte es noch nicht gegeben in
der 4000 einwohner gemeinde die
lauenauer müssen nun extrem wasser
sparen weil wir sonst sehr schnell
wieder in einem äußerst kritischen
situation werden es braucht nur wenige
stunden und es ist wieder das alte bild
hier eigentlich kein lauenau genug
wasser aus der nahegelegenen geister
quelle beziehen
doch der wasserspeicher lief der grund
die extreme hitze und der massiv
angestiegene privat verbrauch von
trinkwasser in gärten unter anderem für
puls zeitweise mussten erste freibäder
schließen deutschland habe kein
trinkwasser problem sagen experten
die öffentliche trinkwasserversorgung
für die millionen menschen in
deutschland ist gesichert und das auch
für die nächsten monate kein
flächendeckendes problem sondern ein
punktuelles wie hier in grävenwiesbach
im hochtaunuskreis die bürger dürfen
seit anfang des monats weder den rasen
sprengen noch autos waschen oder den
pool füllen
die maßnahmen sind sehr drastisch also
das ist wahnsinn armutszeugnis finde ich
selber dass wir jetzt hier in der
gemeinde kein wasser mehr entnehmen darf
in den wasserverbrauch aufs mindeste
herunterfahren
auch der bürgermeister holt sein wasser
aus dem örtlichen brunnen
wir haben im dritten jahr hintereinander
in sehr trockenen sommer kaum winter
kein schneefall keine niederschläge und
dazu sicherlich noch die
außergewöhnliche pandemie situation die
sich ja auch zu einem höheren
wasserverbrauch führte im
niedersächsischen lauenau greifen die
menschen bis sich die situation
entspannt auf trinkwasser im supermarkt
zurück und nun zum sport und zum aus von
leverkusen in der europa league norbert
ja ein bitteres 1 zu 2 im viertelfinale
gegen inter mailand große enttäuschung
wieder eine saison ohne titel
aber gestern abend war mailand einfach
eine nummer zu groß vor allem wegen des
großartigen stürmerstars lukaku
der mann des spiels romelu lukaku von
inter mailand immer anspielbar fällt
nach seinem abpraller das 1 0 für die
italiener durch nicola barella das 2 0
erzielt der belgische nationalstürmer
selbst und ist damit der erste spieler
überhaupt der in neun
aufeinanderfolgenden europa league
partien trifft leverkusen wird meist
ideenlos und ist nur einmal erfolgreich
anschlusstreffer durch kai harbach mit
dieser 1 2 viertelfinalniederlage
verabschiedet sich leverkusen als
letzter bundesligist aus der europa
league
gestern hatten die gesundheitsminister
den dfl plänen zur zulassung von
zuschauern in den stadien zum
saisonstart am 18 september eine
vorläufige absage erteilt heute erklärte
die deutsche fußball-liga sie
respektiere diese position die
eindämmung des corona virus habe höchste
priorität
laut der gesundheitsminister sei wegen
der gestiegenen infektionszahlen dann
eine rückkehr der fans vor dem 31
oktober nicht zu denken der schwere
unfall von radprofi fabian cops und bei
der polen-rundfahrt zeigte erneut wie
gefährlich massensprint sein können
jetzt fordern einige fahrer konsequenzen
zielsprint sind immer gefährlich große
mengen an fahrern hohes tempo wenig
platz und instabile absperrungen der
sturz des niederländers jacobsen gibt
anlass genug dazu darüber nachzudenken
wie solche situationen vermieden werden
können
die gitter angeht ich denke das wird
auch auf jeden fall noch einmal
untersucht
man hat ja eindeutig gesehen dass die in
alle richtungen geflogen sind beispiel
für mehr sicherheit die tour 2017 mark
cavendish rutscht an einer stabilen
absperrung einfach ab die bandenwerbung
genutzt einfach fest sein und kann kann
nicht dann über die rennstrecke fliegen
vor allem gilt es diese bergab ankunft
in kattowitz zu entschärfen tempo 80
beim sprint 20 km h mehr als üblich
fahrer veranstalter und weltverband sind
also gefordert mehr für sicherheit als
für spektakuläre show zu sorgen klare
sache sicherlich zuerst muss auch im rat
spricht unbedingt die hitze schlägt auch
heute wieder in unwetter um aktuell
warnt der deutsche wetterdienst
vor schweren gewittern in rheinland
pfalz und bayern schon am nachmittag
krachte es über einigen regionen hier
bei chemnitz zum beispiel stand in
kürzester zeit alles unter wasser
teilweise gab es auch heftige
hagelschauer auch über nordrhein
westfalen zum gewitter
einige straßen wie die a40 waren
überflutet ja und heiß und gewittrig
geht es auch morgen weiter mehr zum
explosiven besser gleich von katja
schäfer
das war es von uns für heute danke für
ihr interesse
claus kleber freut sich später auf sie
im heute journal und wir freuen uns wenn
sie morgen wieder mit dabei sind um 19
uhr einen schönen abend noch
[Musik]
meine damen und herren neben der hitze
sind derzeit die gewitter das thema bei
uns nicht nur mitteleuropa hier in
deutschland sondern auch westlich von
uns südwestlich von paris entwickelten
sich heute nachmittag kräftige gewitter
türme und diese kreisförmigen zirn
schirme wie entdecken wir auch hier über
dem apennin auch jetzt am abend gibt es
noch einige gewitter und am längsten
halten die sich in der ersten
nachthälfte hier zwischen dem sauerland
und dem saarland das wird wieder eine
sehr warme nach dem westen sinken die
temperaturen kaum unter 23 bis 20 grad
angenehmer werden die temperaturen im
nordosten in den mittelgebirgen und am
alpenrand bei 17 bis 14 grad
der tag morgen bringt dann wieder
schweißtreibende werte zwischen 30 und
35 grad angenehm ist es dagegen in
schleswig holstein an der ostsee und am
alpenrand bei 24 bis 29 grad viel sonne
gibt es am vormittag dann wird es die
sich dunstig gibt einige quellwolken und
es entwickeln sich wieder zum teil
kräftige gewitter vielleicht im
schwarzwald an der mosel vielleicht aber
sogar im münster hat wird lässt sich von
aller und elbe da strahlt die sonne bei
ostwind und nach den hitzegewittern am
donnerstag wird es am freitag und
samstag ganz verbreitet in deutschland
gewittern
schönen abend noch